عبد السلام ما الذي يحدث في ليبيا بطبيعه
الحال كل الارقام والاحصاءات تدل على ان
عدد المفقودين وعدد الضحايا يزداد بشكل
متسارع اخر احصائيه تقول بان عدد
القتلى تجاوز 2300 حتى هذه اللحظه بينما
عدد المفقودين تجاوز اكثر من خمسه الاف هي
كارثه بكل ما تحمله الكلمه من معنى لم
يشهدها هذا البلد العربي منذ اكثر من
اربعين عاما عدد الاسر التي نزحت من
بيوتها الان تجاوز عشرين الف عائله هناك
اشكاليات كثيره تتعلق باللوجستيات لايصال
الدعم والمساعدات الى مدينه درنه التي
تضررت بسبب العواصف
والسيول التي نتجت عن انهيار سدين في
مدينه درنا بعد ان ضرب المدينه اعصار
دانيال بطبيعه الحال هناك اشكاليات
لوجستيه تتعلق بايصال الدعم لابد ان يصل
فقط عن طريق الجو او عن طريق البحر حكومه
ليبيا حكومه الوحده الوطنيه بقياده عبد
الحميد الدبيبه ارسلت واعلنت ارسال
مساعدات عن طريق بنغازي ايضا في الجهه
الشرقيه من ليبيا يتم تجهيز عدد من
المساعدات لارسالها الى المناطق المتضرره
لكن صعوبات كثيره منها الصعوبات اللوجستيه
تعرقل عمليات الاغاثه والانقاذ مما حدى
عدد من الدول الخارجيه للتدخل منها تركيا
التي وصلت بالفعل مساعدات من جهات معنيه
بموضوع انقاذ
الناجين من الفيضانات على سبيل المثال
وكاله افاد وهي وكاله متخصصه في الانقاذ
والكوارث
الطبيعيه اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر
اعلنت انها ستقدم ما يمكن تقديمه من
مساعدات لكن القلق ينتاب الجميع في ليبيا
بسبب عدد المفقودين هناك حديث من مسؤولين
في الحكومه الليبيه يتحدث بان مدينه درنه
ربما يمحى منها 25%
وبانها لم تعد قابله للحياه في هذه الاونه
وبانه يمكن اخلاء المدينه